cortney's with us atlanta hi Kourtni
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how you doing better than I deserve
what's up
Wow sign up for SPU today yeah hey good
question I have for you okay sweet
question I have for you I want to know
you know how they has those College
College how you pay back your student
loans with those programs after 10 years
is forgiven
yeah what do you suggest is better do
you suggest it's better to pay it off if
the debt snowball or enroll in one of
those programs and okay I had a snowball
because I don't want to wait 10 years to
be free that's what I was thinking
that's what I was thinking okay how much
standing alone that we you have oh it's
me and my husband have quite a bit my
husband is about almost 100 and I have
60 160,000 who's the doctor or lawyer
I'm a nursing school teach in household
income household income last year it was
110 mmm okay
yeah it's a mess that's a mess them on
well you guys are it's going to take you
a little while and you're going to you
know pretty much take your lifestyle
down to nothing but I mean if we take
160 and we divide it by 4 that's 40,000
a year that puts you out of debt in four
years if you do it on if you divide it
by 3 that's 55,000 and then puts you out
of debt in 3 years you probably do it in
3 but you're going to be working more
than you're working now I mean like as a
nurse you can pick up stuff everywhere
and make money that's that's the good
news and the bad news and as a teacher
he's going to be doing some tutoring and
stuff remember everything we can and
let's turn that hundred and ten under
150 and let's trust actually tutoring
right now yeah try to do it try to do it
in three years with you know turn 110
into 150 but that's a temporary thing
because you can be working all the time
to do that have no life but the good
news is you'll get rid of this mess
and you don't wait ten years to do it
you can do it in four but I try to do it
in three but really cranking it up how
much other debt not counting your house
and student loans do you have um we have
the cars and they total how much I owe
twelve I think he owes fifteen on his
done that's it besides the house good
have the cars not really no medical
medical just a little 300 maybe here and
there not a bunch of credit card no
credit card good well you know what you
do is you wait into this thing you get
into financial university you get
started and what normally happens with
folks Cortney when you're sitting there
right now you're just sitting there for
the first time and you just walked up to
the bottom of Mount Everest and looked
up and you went oh my goodness that's a
long climb you know well what what's
where it is when you climb for a few
days and you're at base camp and then
you look up and you go that's still
always up there but I think I can do
this it's a different feeling when
you're halfway up or quarter the way up
then and then you feel today
and once that hope starts to kick in you
start being willing to sacrifice and
work more and that kind of stuff and you
tend to increase the speed at which you
get out of debt as you go along because
the because the the goal is more Within
Reach as you go along does that make
sense
we're day it's all like brand new and
in-your-face and overwhelming what but a
year from duty after you've been working
on this for a year and let's say after a
year you paid off forty or forty-five
thousand dollars can you see how your
emotions might have shifted after that
yes and you go oh yeah yeah we got this
matter of fact let's turn it up a notch
or two you know and you that's what ends
up happening as people go along it's not
a straight line set of math usually it's
a set of map that as you go along you
increase the amount that you're paying
on the debt most people do is they walk
through a two a three a four year plan
and you're looking at a you know a three
year plan a four year plan something
like that and that's what very focused
intensity but you can do it and as
you're going through Financial Peace
University if you've gained questions
you call me I'll walk with you you got
this you can do it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]